NBA players were not quite on Twitter
when they found out kylian mbappe was
offered almost a billion dollars to play
one season Giannis was one of the first
to comment on mbappe's insane offer
saying that Allah could take him because
he looks like mbappe LeBron followed up
posting a gift showing how quickly he'd
be at Saudi Arabia's door if they
offered him a contract like that
Draymond Green tweeted asking if Saudi
Arabia had any basketball leagues and
said he doesn't think the ink on his
current contract has dried up quite yet
Dame was just shocked just to put in
bape's offered contract into a little
bit of perspective Jalen Brown just
signed the richest deal in NBA history
and what he makes in one season is not
even eight percent of what mbappe would
make in one season and Bobby's one
season salary would be worth more than
the combined salaries of the 15 highest
paid NBA players for the 2023 and 2024
season